blut symbolisiert den schmerz die blüte
steht für hoffnung und der zeichenstift
verwandelt den schmerz in hoffnung
es ist die hoffnung auf frieden und
freiheit
der zeichner hanni abbas hat zusammen
mit seiner familie in genf asyl
beantragt vor zwei jahren mussten sie
aus syrien fliehen
angst zerstörung tod all das haben sie
hinter sich gelassen
wenn ich an die freunde und verwandten
in syrien denke an die vielen
flüchtlinge wird mir bewusst wie groß
meine verantwortung ist die stimme
meines volkes überall hörbar zu machen
natürlich bin ich froh jetzt in einem
sicheren land wie der schweiz lehner zu
dürfen
meine gedanken aber sind immer bei
meinem volk
in seinen zeichnungen gibt hanni abbas
dem unaussprechlichen eine form
eines seiner berühmtesten werke ist der
schrei von syrien
diese zeichnung wurde zum symbol des
widerstands gegen das assad regime
hanni abbas bringt sich mit seiner
arbeit in lebensgefahr wird verfolgt und
bedroht
natürlich hatte ich angst oft fragte ich
mich ob ich eine zeichnung publizieren
sollte oder nicht
nur schon ob ich sie auf facebook
stellen sollte mein finger wollte die
taste zum senden drücken mein kopf
zögerte nein nein
doch bezeichnungen brachten mich oft in
schwierigkeiten
aber am ende habe ich alles publiziert
heute verkauft er seine karikaturen an
zeitschriften in der ganzen welt und
muss dabei nicht mehr um sein leben
fürchten
oder etwa doch die anschläge auf das
satire magazin l'hebdo am 17 januar in
paris haben gezeigt dass zeichne auch im
westen unter umständen gefährlich leben
ich war schockiert nach dem attentat
terror darf man nie akzeptieren oder
rechtfertigen
wir müssen für die freiheit einstehen
besonders für die meinungsfreiheit wenn
ich persönlich etwas sehe habe ich die
wahl es zu mögen oder es zu ignorieren
es gibt keinen grund auf gedanken mit
mord zu reagieren das ist sehr traurig
hanni abbas verarbeiteten terror in
paris auf seine art die meinungsfreiheit
steht auf dem spiel
zumindest im westen in der arabischen
welt gibt es eine bedingung
meinungsfreiheit ja blasphemie
nein steht auf den plakaten
bei so vielen aufgebrachten menschen
stellt sich die frage ob satire grenzen
haben soll bevor ich etwas publiziere
überlege ich ob die karikatur unnötig
jemanden provoziert er nichts mit dem
problem zu tun hat auf das sich
aufmerksam machen möchte satire sollte
immer im auftrag des friedens stehen
anstatt krieg zu provozieren
seine bilder sind dafür das sprechende
beispiel im letzten frühjahr überreichte
im kofi annan den quatschen in for peace
prize in genf eine große ehre für den
syrischen flüchtlinge und eine
bestätigung dass seine arbeit als
zeichner international wirkung zeigt
der freie gedanke ist die gefährlichste
und effektivste waffe gegen radikale
mächte und gegengewalt
hania buzz kämpft für die
meinungsfreiheit in einer demokratischen
welt hier in genf in gedanken in syrien